okay so the topic of this video is
deoxyribonucleic acid or better known as
DNA so let's go ahead and get started
talking about DNA okay so what is DNA
well here's a fairly simplistic
definition right here it's a molecule
that stores genetic information you know
you're often going to hear DNA compared
to a blueprint and in the picture here's
a blueprint you can kind of tell it's a
blueprint to build a boat you know bloop
it drew a blueprint excuse me a
blueprint is really simply a set of
building instructions and so that makes
a blueprint a wonderful analogy for what
DNA is DNA is a blueprint in what we're
going to show in a throughout this video
and others is that DNA are blueprints
here is a blueprint that tells cells how
to build proteins and we'll talk more
about that in a moment if you recall
from earlier in the school year we
talked about monomers and polymers when
we were discussing organic molecules and
we mentioned that there's four
categories of organic molecules you know
nucleic acids is one carbohydrates is a
second lipids is a third and proteins is
a fourth and and all four kinds of
organic molecules are made from small
monomers small basic units and so the
basic unit or the monomer of nucleic
acids are what we call nucleotides and
here's a picture of a nucleotide let's
see a nucleotide is made from three sub
parts you have a sugar group you have a
phosphate group and then you have what's
called the nitrogen base we're going to
again talk more about nucleotides in a
few moments but here's just a refresher
if we remind ourselves of what nucleic
acids are again they are millions and
millions of nucleotides bonded in a big
chain DNA for instance is bonded in a
double chain there's a there's a left
side to the DNA molecule there's a right
side and so in this little simplistic
picture here we see that all these a's
and t's and c's and g's these are parts
of nucleotides and they're all bonded to
make one big spiral twisted spot
I roll a molecule called DNA we're going
to talk more about these A's and T's and
C's in G's in a moment so if we kind of
take a moment and look at this picture
you know here's a picture of DNA and
from the picture how many nucleotides do
you see in this picture you know pause
the video if you want 30 seconds or so
to look it over I'm going to go over the
answer in 3 2 1
so how many nucleotides are in this
picture well there's one nucleotide a
phosphate of sugar and then a nitrogen
base labeled a well here's a second
nucleotide a third a fourth a fifth a
sixth nucleotide every nucleotide has a
phosphate a sugar and one of the four
nitrogen bases in it either the nitrogen
base a c or g adenine thymine cytosine
or guanine so you see there's six
nucleotides on the left of this picture
well there's a seventh there's an eighth
thousand nine ten eleven twelve there's
six nucleotides on the left six
nucleotides on the right so there's a
total of twelve nucleotides in this
picture every nucleotide consisting of a
phosphate a sugar and one of four
different kinds of nitrogen bases so if
we kind of come back to these notes
really quick and we and we look at the
same same picture that we see here what
we actually see these a's and t's and
c's and g's that we can read this is
actually symbolic of a gene but gene is
a small piece of DNA and it what it does
is it holds instructions to build a
protein earlier I mentioned that DNA is
often compared to a blueprint a
blueprint is a set of instructions to
build something so for instance in the
picture I just highlighted for instance
this gene pretend this is a gene this is
a set of instructions here to make a
protein called hemoglobin you might know
hemoglobin is the protein found in red
blood cells that helps to transport
oxygen so genes are small pieces of DNA
small pieces of those a's t's c's and
g's and they instruct our cells on how
to build a protein and we're going to
learn how they do that another day in
another video but that's kind of a sneak
peek
so let's look at nucleotides and a
little more depth
you know nucleotides we said earlier are
made from three basic parts and in this
picture we see one of the three parts we
see the sugar molecule the name of the
sugar molecule of DNA goes by the name
of deoxyribose you know there's
something in the way that deoxyribose is
spelled that lets you know it's a sugar
anytime you see molecules end with OSE
that's a giveaway that they are a sugar
molecule you think of other sugars
you've heard of you've heard of sucrose
fructose glucose lactose and now in this
case deoxyribose it's the name of the
sugar that makes up DNA molecules you're
often going to see the sugar molecule
the deoxyribose simply illustrated in
diagrams as a Pentagon and that's simply
because the atoms that make up the AXI
ribose are themselves arranged in a
pentagon shape so for simplicity you're
often going to see the deoxyribose of a
DNA simply drawn as a pentagon a second
part of a nucleotide is called the
phosphate group and here's the actual
atoms that make up the phosphate
molecule and notice how there's a
phosphorus in the middle also for
simplicity you're often going to see the
phosphate groups simply drawn as a
circle maybe with a pea in the middle
for phosphate but really for just for
simplicity we're going to illustrate the
phosphate molecules as circles so what
is unique about everybody's DNA and on
earth is we all have a unique
combination of nitrogen bases there's
four different kinds of nitrogen bases
you might know a nitrogen base labeled a
for adenine a nitrogen base T four
thymine C for cytosine and G for guanine
and I said a moment ago that everybody
in everyone on earth has a unique
combination of a's t's c's and g's well
that's true except for identical twins
identical twins have the exact same
combination but everybody else on the
earth we all have a unique blueprint a
unique combination of Adnan's and
thymines inside
and guanine zits what makes each one of
us genetically unique well in this
picture here are the four different
kinds of nucleotides and notice how they
each have the sugar the pentagon shaped
sugar they each have the round phosphate
molecules so how are the four
nucleotides in the picture here how are
they different from one another how did
these four nucleotides differ from one
another what's not the sugar it's the
same it's not the phosphate it's the
same how they differ is by the type of
nitrogen base that you see the adenine
and the thiamine the cytosine and the
guanine let's talk about these a z' t's
c's and g's in more detail so
nucleotides will combine to make nucleic
acids we mentioned that a nucleotide is
a monomer so here we have the nucleotide
with with an a for adenine in the
picture watch what happens here's one
nucleotide and here we have a bunch of
nucleotides have just bonded with that
original a that we saw
I now see 1 2 3 4 5 I now see 6
nucleotides bonded together this would
be this be on our way to making DNA a
nucleic acid if we remember our 1
chargaff in chargaff's rules and what
aaron chargaff discovered was DNA always
had an equal amount of adenine and
thymine he didn't quite know why and we
and he also found out that DNA molecules
had an equal amount of cytosine and
guanine again he didn't really know why
it took years of investigation for us to
figure out why adenine was always equal
in the mountain to thymine and why
cytosine was always equal in amount to
guanine the reason we now know that a
czar our equality's is because they bond
and pair with one another from the top
down if you have a site as e and a C on
the Left bonded to that on the right
will be a G for guanine so if you have a
T on the left bond it to that will be an
A for adenine the third one down will be
a T the fourth one down will be a C the
fifth one down will be a T the sixth one
down will be a
gee so these are what we are now known
as as chargaff's rules after urban
chargaff and so what we have here is a
picture of 12 nucleotides bonded
together to make a nucleic acid I have
six nucleotides on the left and six
nucleotides on the right now if you also
notice there are what are called six
pairs these are called base pairs six
pairs of a's and t's and c's and g's in
the picture so one thing i want you to
know is DNA is a really large molecule
for instance the entire human genome and
the word genome simply means all of the
DNA so all of human DNA in packed into
the nucleus of every cell in our body
we've counted there's over three billion
pairs of a's and T's and season G's
packed into every nucleus of every cell
in our body so DNA is is a rather large
molecule in in this simplistic diagram
here I have six base pairs nitrogen base
pairs but in reality DNA molecules are
really large if I just give a simpler
diagram of a DNA molecule here I've
given you a G ATT a CA now the reason I
chose these letters is because if you've
ever seen the movie Gattaca
a science fiction movie came out in the
late 1990s called Gattaca wonderful
science fiction movie for those of you
who like sci-fi I very much recommend
you know checking it out a Netflix or
something and it's just a fun view of
genetic engineering perhaps in the in
our future in but the name Gattaca
really isn't a name at all the people
that made the movie Gattaca they just
took the four nitrogen bases of DNA a z'
t c's and g's and they tried to arrange
those four letters into something that
resembled a title for a movie and they
came up with the name Gattaca they
easily could have done this they easily
could have named the movie citta to
Jetta but it doesn't roll off the tongue
as well as Gattaca does but if you
remember chargaff's rules if you have a
G then there's going to be a
see if you have a tea there's going to
be an a chargaff's rule so when we look
at the structure of DNA the double helix
it's called in 1953 these two gentlemen
here that James Watson on the left
Francis Crick on the right
they built a model that that explained
how the structure of DNA was arranged
how the atoms were arranged in the
overall molecule of DNA and what they
concluded was that DNA is in the shape
of a double helix and also that adenine
pairs the thiamine appears to T and that
cytosine pairs to guanine C pairs to G
and F before this discovery there was
some debate as to how or the nitrogen
base is arranged or they arranged in the
inside of the double helix or on the
outside and so through some research
they were able to conclude that the
nitrogen bases are on the inside now
that research you might know the back
story that research kind of involves the
lady here in the bottom of this picture
here rosalind Franklin and a fairly
famous photograph that she made on top
here this is called photo 51 and this is
a picture that she made using x-ray
crystallography to produce an image of a
DNA molecule and then through some
through some fairly complex math Watson
and Crick were able to determine this
the structure of DNA from this picture
sadly there's kind of a back story as
how as to how Watson and Crick obtained
this picture you guys can read about
that on your own if you'd like and so
what we now know about the structure of
DNA and the double helix molecule is
that nucleotide remember if there's a a
nucleotide on the left there'll be a T
nucleotide on the right and what holds
them together is there's order called
the hydrogen bonds in between the A's
and the T's and hydrogen bonds in
between the CS and the GS and that's
what the flashing lines in this picture
are supposed to represent the hydrogen
bonds it's what holds the a and T
together and the CMG together and so one
of the one of the one of the
breakthroughs that James Watson and
Francis Crick described in their
research paper when they described
the structure of DNA is there they
immediately saw a way in which DNA could
be copied or replicated and that's what
DNA replication is it's the process of
how DNA is copied and this takes place
during the s stage of interphase we
talked about this cell cycle and
interphase earlier in the school year
but during the process of DNA
replication one piece of DNA one
molecule of DNA will be copied into two
and if you wonder why do cells make
copies of DNA well because cells are
always multiplying when one cell
multiplies into two cells both of those
cells need a copy of the DNA so there
has to be a way to duplicate the DNA and
that's what I want to talk about right
now in this process called DNA
replication I'm going to break it down
into three steps step one is there's an
enzyme by the name of DNA helicase now
look how I spelled it I underlined ASE
helicase ASE anytime you see molecules
with an ASE ending that's a giveaway
that the molecule is an enzyme earlier
we saw words that end in OSE OSE are
sugar ASE is an enzyme so enzymes if you
recall are our types of proteins and
they help to speed up chemical reactions
they reduce the energy needed for a
chemical reaction to occur and so in my
simplistic animation a DNA helicase is
represented by this animated scissors
what the DNA helicase does is it breaks
apart the bonds holding the a and the T
holding the C and the G so one by one
DNA helicase will break apart the Barn's
the hydrogen bonds between the A's and
the T's the seas and the GS and that
causes our DNA molecule to separate to
open up like you just saw in the
animation well what happens next what's
step two so step two is keep in mind
this is all in the nucleus of the cell
this is where DNA is found in you know
the nucleus it's not filled with empty
hollow air space there's a fluid in the
nucleus much like the cytoplasm and
there are molecules dissolved in that
fluid of the nucleus and so our
directions say free-floating nuclei
sites free-floating Adnan's and thymines
and cytosines and guanines match up so
look on the left strip of DNA I have a C
on top top left I have a C well I hope
you a G for guanine will flow down in
and match up the next one down is a T so
when a is going to float in the next one
down I have an A on the left so a T will
float in the next one down here comes a
see the next one down here comes a T the
next one down here comes a G well the
same thing happens to the DNA on the
right of the screen only replication
takes place in the opposite direction so
in this case we're going to start at the
bottom and work our way up there's a G
on the bottom here comes a C next next
one up there's a T on the right here
comes an A next one up here comes a G
next here is an adenine next here's a
thymine next here's a cytosine and so
what we've created here are two pieces
of DNA now we're not quite done but
that's kind of the main gist of it right
there but let's finish these up step 3
there's an enzyme and a different enzyme
by the name of DNA polymerase that helps
to reconnect the two strands and I'm
being a little simplistic here by in
light by illustrating DNA polymerase as
a bottle of glue and it helps to glue
and bond the add means the thymines and
the guanine cytosine is all together and
so there's this enzyme called DNA
polymerase that helps to reconnect and
REE bond and basically zip up the DNA
and complete this process and when the
process is finished I hope you notice
both strands of DNA are identical look
at the the letter code on the top c and
g to the left on the right cng next
letters down TNA next letters down TNA
next letters down a NT and then a NT the
identical the the DNA strands are
identical to one another well you know
in the creation of all these a's and t's
and c's and g's remember there's 3
billion 3 billion pairs of a's and t's
and c's and d's per cell
of course there is the chance of a
mistake being made and we call these
mistakes mutations you know Hollywood's
got it all wrong if you watch a
Hollywood movie they're going to show
you they're going to convince you that
mutations allow you to shoot lasers out
of your eyes and control the weather
with your mind and bend metal and
control metal with your thoughts who I'm
thinking of the x-men movies but you
know that's not really accurate as far
as what mutations are a mutation is a
change in our DNA sequence notice in the
animation here I've highlighted a red
letter C C and a they don't bond
together so that's clearly a misspelling
right there this is an example of a
mutation the good news is his mutations
are often corrected we have enzymes that
are act as a little proof readers and
spell checkers what they'll do I'm going
to illustrate the enzyme again with my
little animated scissors here so in my
animated scissors they've found that
that mutation the red letter C and the
reason there's anime think I think
scissors are a good analogy here is
because the enzyme will cut out and
remove the mutation and once the C for
cytosine has been cut out that will
allow the proper nitrogen base to fill
in thus repairing the mutation and you
know we've actually estimated pre repair
before any of these mutations are fixed
it's estimated there's about one error
one misspelling one mutation in every
10,000 nucleotides that might not seem
like a lot but remember that the human
genome is made up of three billion pairs
of a's and t's and c's and g's if
there's one mistake out of every 10,000
that's millions of errors right there
but after the mutations are repaired we
estimate that there's only about one
mistake in every billion or so so you
know there are no perfect samples we are
all flawed every person has 3 4 5 6 7 8
mutations and we just hope that those
mutations are not in key locations of
our DNA that could cause undue suffering
so there you go there's a brief
introduction in
the world of DNA deoxyribonucleic acid
if you're in my biology class you know
pause the video try to answer these five
questions you know write your answers on
a separate sheet of paper I'd be happy
to check them for accuracy good luck